Do the drug hormone blockers work really fast to reduce tumors?
People can take the drug hormone blockers and it doesn't reduce the tumor at all. So
people can take the drug hormone blockers and it does
reduce the tumor. But I wouldn't say anything. He's gonna work really fast.
You know the kid it's just
It's hard to give these clear black and white answers to these things is
Everybody's different and how you react to something is gonna be very different than somebody else
so
Do you know the body bounces back or be thrown into the metapause you will go into a medically
Induced metapause right away. That's how you know it's working. So
If you know that it's not working at all. So you really I mean that's the whole purpose of those drugs is to take away all your estrogens
So